the 1980s a man named John Azarian began
collecting the Mobilio from the
television shows he'd grown up with from
Batman the star attracts a Wonder Woman
he snapped up props costumes and other
items eventually forming a treasure
trove of collectibles with few rivals
now part of that collection is going up
for sale in California the funds are
really curse cannot be broken it's
ridiculous to try that's it that's all
and that's goodbye
[Music]
[Applause]
it's considered the holy grail of
classic TV collectibles Fonzie's leather
jacket actor Henry Winkler wore several
versions during happy days 11th season
run one ended up in the Smithsonian in
Washington where it's one of the most
popular exhibits and later this week
another is headed to the auction block
part of an extraordinary collection of
more than 200 items gathered over the
decades by classic TV fan John Azarian I
started collecting because I'm a child
of the sixties these are the shows that
I grew up with that I loved as a child
and I had still watched today and for me
to own some of the pieces from these
shows was just beyond words and once I
was able to acquire and start buying
these pieces it just built up in me and
I had to keep buying more assyrians
collection maybe the finest in the
nation covering a slew of classic shows
there's Gilligan's hat and the skipper's
to hand me that bamboo pole perhaps a
little worn from all the times he used
it on his first mate and other costumes
from Wonder Woman
[Music]
the Flying Nun
[Music]
I Dream of Jeannie and Star Trek
as Aryan collected items from all the
shows he loved but his first love was
Batman the campy and psychedelic 60s
version holy pincushions one of the
first items he acquired the only known
pair of complete Batman and Robin
costumes worn by Adam West and Burt Ward
as Aryans only stipulation on that sale
the dynamic duo's cape clothing has to
be purchased as a pair they cannot be
separated they must stay together they
are the dynamic duo
can you imagine separating Batman and
Robin no way they have to be together as
to why he's selling now it was very
difficult for me to actually pull the
trigger and make the decision to sell
part of my collection the part that I am
selling I just think it's time let's
somebody else treasure them and honor
them the way I have for last 30 years
and I am told that some of that stuff is
going going gone Jeff you had on one of
these things what would it be
Wonder Woman oh the Captain Kirk v-neck
buy that wear it next week all right
fine